The tension in the air was palpable.
Everyone sat around the long oak table was
sweating in their business suits, tugging
at their ties so that it might dislodge the
collective lumps in everyone’s throats.
At the head of the table, someone sat facing
away from the rest of the gathered executives,
their silk-gloved hands interlocked, the crown
of a top hat just visible over the back of
their broad, throne-like chair.
“So, my friends,” they said without turning
around, in a voice that filled the boardroom,
“What a sorry state of affairs this is.
The SCP Foundation sticking their noses in,
sniffling around the company, shutting down
factories.
And then there are our customers, too obsessed
with Fortnite to be interested in the toys
we’re making.
If Wondertainment Enterprises can't touch
the hearts of every man, woman, and child
on the planet, then what are we even doing
here?
What’s our point?”
A pause lingered.
Nobody in the room knew whether to answer
or keep quiet and let somebody else speak
first.
“That wasn’t a rhetorical question!”
the voice yelled from its chair.
“We are a company that makes toys.
That is our point, and that’s why you’re
here.
So, go ahead, don’t be shy.
Pitch me something.”
After another moment of silence, one of the
board members nervously stood up from his
chair.
Attempting to straighten his tie, he produced
a box containing a prototype.
“Uh, I might have something, Doctor,”
he said, nervously struggling to compose himself.
“Go on.”
Opening the box, the man produced a small
circular, spinning top with jagged edges – or
a Beyblade, to those born after 1999.
“So, nineties nostalgia is b-back in right
now,” the executive stammered, assembling
the Beyblade in his shaking hands.
“And Wondertainment Industries can be the
first to relaunch this popular playground
craze from back in the day.”
He pulled on the ripcord, letting the spinning
toy loose on the desk.
Instead of spiraling in a circle though, the
Beyblade shot across the table’s surface
and hopped down to the floor, a tiny voice
emanating from it the entire time.
“No, no, please don’t make me fight!
I can’t.
I won’t do it!
I don’t want to die,” it sobbed as it
raced across the floor and out of the door.
Realizing he didn’t need to say anything
else, the board member sat back down.
Another stood up, more eager now that somebody
else had gone first.
“Well, we were thinking something more for
the younger market,” she declared.
She produced a large flashcard that displayed
an image of a pretty ordinary-looking hobby
horse.
“You can’t really go wrong with a classic,
right?”
she asked, looking around the room for any
looks of approval from the rest of the board.
“Anyway, these hobby horses are durable.
They come in a range of colors…
there’s just, um, one little caveat.
We got some calls from the Italian Prime Minister
after we’d been testing them.
Apparently, at the exact same time someone
rocks on one of these hobby horses, a random
person in Italy gets turned to dust.
We currently have… um, no way of counteracting
this.”
There were a few short murmurs from the rest
of the board.
Sensing she was losing them, the same executive
signaled her assistant, who retrieved something
from outside the boardroom.
As she re-entered, she was holding a teddy
bear at arm’s length, grimacing in disgust.
The rest of the board quickly realized why;
the bear carried with it a pungent stench
that hung heavy in the air.
“Keeping with that younger market I was
talking about,” the exec piped up again,
holding her nose shut.
“Kids love gross-out humor, right?
You put a fart in an animated movie, and the
tykes go nuts for it.
So, this… delightful product – ‘the
Stinky Bear’ – can bring that same enjoyment
into the home for the low price of $39.99!”
“Are those the same bears that R&D was testing
a while back?” one of the other Wondertainment
executives asked.
“The ones that had a one in five chance
of releasing lethal amounts of Novichok?”
“Wait, isn’t that a Russian nerve agent?”
another exclaimed in horror.
“Get that Stinky Bear out of here!”
Defeated, the presenting executive retook
her seat while her assistant carried the bear
to the incinerator.
“Well, this has been a poor show thus far,”
came the good doctor’s voice from the far
end of the table, interrupted by a tinny,
electronic beeping.
“Mr. Glenridge, what is that in your pocket?”
“Oh, sorry, feeding time,” the board member,
Mr. Glenridge, apologized, pulling out a tiny,
oval-shaped device and, oddly enough, a candy
bar.
“It’s a Tamagotchi.
You remember those, right?
Well, we whipped up this one to be more intelligent,
but it keeps demanding actual, solid food,
so I just have to…”
Glenridge then proceeded to tear open the
candy wrapper and begin mushing it into the
Tamagotchi’s LCD screen.
The virtual pet made a number of sad-sounding
beeps, almost like it was crying over its
own lack of tastebuds.
“I think that the problem here is obvious!”
a stuffier, older member of the board – Mr.
Omer – spoke up.
“Look, we all know that the dang kids are
too distracted by their darn cell phones these
days.
And sure, we could sit here and try to get
them interested in the anomalous entertainment
we’re trying to sell them.
Or we could try to profit off them by going
after what we know they’re already obsessed
with.”
“I really don’t think you should pursue
this train of thought, Mr. Omer,” an executive
named Mx, Clarron interjected.
“No, this is a good idea!”
Omer protested.
“It’s simple.
We develop an app, a video game that the kids
won’t be able to get enough of.
But here’s the catch: in order to progress
in the game, we can encourage them to spend
real cash in exchange for some kind of virtual
currency that can only be used in the app
itself.
It’d essentially be worthless, useless even,
anywhere other than inside our game.
But if they want to be the best at it, then
the kids will have to keep coughing over the
dough.
And hey, we could even throw in some colonel-grade
spyware too, so when they have the app on
their phones, it simultaneously harvests all
their personal data and-”
At the snap of the doctor’s gloved fingers,
Mr Omer was suddenly vaporized, letting off
one final shriek as he turned into a pile
of ash on the table.
“I think Mr. Omer failed to realize that
many other companies already beat us to the
punch with that idea,” Doctor Wondertainment
sighed, exasperated.
“And besides, we aren’t monsters.
Somebody else take the floor…
please.”
“W-well,” Mx Clarron mumbled, standing
up, wiping some of Mr. Omer’s ash off their
glasses, “Our social media team has been
doing some research into current online trends.
And it turns out, we might have something
that fits with a really popular one.”
Clarron produced a pristine doll’s house,
a to-scale recreation of a single-story home
in Albuquerque, New Mexico.
They opened up the walls, revealing a group
of figurines inside, each one moving of its
own accord, mimicking verbal speech with a
series of little noises.
Lifting off the house’s plastic roof, a
tiny, sculpted pizza slipped off the tiles.
“So, we built this a while ago, during the
peak of the show’s popularity,” Clarron
explained.
“It’s a doll’s house, the dolls inside
are… somewhat alive, as you can see.
But they’re always acting out the plot of
Breaking Bad, scene-by scene, in broadcast
order.”
Sure enough, one of the dolls was a miniature,
bald-headed Walter White, making some little
squeaks that sounded like it was saying ‘I
am the one who knocks.’
“Breaking Bad has had a major resurgence
in meme culture lately, so this could be a
viable product,” one of the other board
members chimed in.
“Right, exactly!”
Clarron smiled nervously.
“Of course, we’d have to sort out a licensing
agreement with AMC… otherwise, we might
get sued…”
Returning to their seat, Clarron trailed off,
hoping someone else would step in to fill
the latest bout of uncomfortable silence.
Wiping a few smears from his brow, a Mr. Ash
took the floor, his assistant wheeling in
a projector and hooking it up to a laptop.
The rest of the executives couldn’t hear
the imaginary, building drum roll in Ash’s
head as he walked up and began to play a video
clip.
“My fellow board members,” he announced
with a well-rehearsed beaming smile.
“As… interesting as some of these pitches
have been, I believe I may well have something
truly special to show you all.
Behold: the Doctor Wondertainment Zoomatron
Pedal Car!”
Through the projector, the video showed a
large plastic toy car with a crash test dummy
sitting in it.
It gradually began building speed at an impressive
rate for an outdoor toy.
The Zoomatron was whipping around an indoor
testing track faster and faster until it was
little more than a blur, a speeding ring of
constant motion.
The board could just make out the dummy’s
arms flailing limply thanks to the sheer g-force.
“I’m almost afraid to ask,” Mr. Glenridge
cleared his throat and spoke up.
“But exactly how fast does that thing go.”
“I’m very glad you asked!”
Mr. Ash replied excitedly.
“It can reach up to Mach 6, with just an
average amount of pedals per second, or P.P.S.,
if you will.”
“But surely that’s dangerous?”
Mx Clarron queried.
“I mean, an object of that size moving six
times the speed of sound that low to the ground?”
“I won’t deny, there have been a few…
let’s call them ‘teething problems’,”
Ash admitted.
Almost on cue, the video showed a Wondertainment
Enterprises worker stepping accidentally into
the path of the speeding pedal car, only to
vanish in a split second as it whizzed by,
the car shot into, then through, a nearby
wall.
“You have anything else, Mr. Ash?”
Doctor Wondertainment asked impatiently from
their chair.
“I, uh, well I…” he stammered, rummaging
through some papers.
“In a similar vein, we also developed an
electric scooter, you know, like those Bird
ones you see people riding about on a lot.
Doesn’t quite go as fast as the Zoomatron,
so that could potentially be safer… marginally,
I meant to say marginally safer.”
“What’s the catch with this one?”
a board member asked, their exasperation obvious
in their tone.
“It’s probably better if I just show you,”
Mr Ash sighed.
He pressed play on another testing clip, wherein
a Wondertainment employee stood atop their
scooter.
At first, it seemed to be moving normally;
that is, until the camera filming it zoomed
out.
The employee and the scooter were floating
several feet in the air,
“We’re, um, we’re still waiting for
that member of staff to return from their
journey,” he said sheepishly.
“I’ll just sit back down.”
“What if we made a yo-yo out of lasagne?”
Mr. Glenridge asked.
The rest of the board all turned to look at
him confused, before he receded in his chair
out of embarrassment, fiddling with his starving
Tamagotchi in the hopes that the next outlandish
toy idea would make everyone forget what he
had just said.
Luckily enough, one of the execs, Ms. Stevenson,
opened up her briefcase and produced a brightly-colored
stuffed bear.
“If I might bring us back to basics,”
she announced.
“Or ‘bear-sics’ if you’ll pardon the
pun-”
“We won’t,” Doctor Wondertainment said
bluntly.
“Oh… well, allow me to introduce the Doesn’t
Care Bear!”
Stevenson forced a smile, then handed the
bear to the nearest board member.
“What am I supposed to do with this?”
Mr. Ash asked, confused.
“Just press the stomach,” Ms. Stevenson
urged, giving him a wide-eyed glare as if
to say either ‘work with me here’ or ‘please
help’.
Doing as instructed, Ash gave the Doesn’t
Care Bear a gentle squeeze, activating a voice
box somewhere inside it.
“Wow, Marlin, your surgeon really conned
you for those hair plugs,” the bear sneered
cruelly.
Mr. Ash instinctively reached up to his forehead,
where his hairline had been noticeably receding
until only a few months ago, but he’d never
told anyone about his transplant.
In truth, it was something he felt pretty
insecure about.
“I- I don’t know what it meant by that,”
Mr. Ash protested, playing it off with a half-hearted
chuckle.
“Darn thing must be defective.”
“Not as defective as your scalp, Marlin!”
the bear gave another callous jeer.
“Did you seriously think that looked realistic?
Nobody’s hairline is that ruler-straight,
not naturally anyway.
Maybe if you’d been a baker like your dad
wanted you to, you could have avoided all
the stress that made you lose your hair in
the first place.
Then again, you were never that good of a
son to him anyway.”
“How in the hell do you turn this awful
thing off?”
Mr. Ash asked frantically, holding back tears.
“Isn’t it great?”
Ms. Stevenson said, forcing a toothy grin.
“Imagine how great it would be for boosting
kids’ confidence!”
“By honing in on their worst insecurities?”
Mx Clarron raised an eyebrow.
“Presenting them with something they don’t
like about themselves will challenge them
to improve on it,” Stevenson argued, in
an unjustly condescending voice.
“That’s just basic reverse psychology.”
“Deborah, taking a one-day course doesn’t
make you a clinical psychiatrist,” the Doesn’t
Care Bear retorted in its cutesy voice.
“You know, you really aren’t as smart
as you want people to think you are.”
“How about a modern update of an old classic?”
Mr. Jefferies, an older executive spoke up,
excitedly setting up something on the table
in front of him.
It was a pair of foldable playing boards,
with a collection of tiny ships, each one
a different size and shape.
“Mx Clarron, if you’d be so kind,” he
said, passing them one half of the board game.
“That’s just Battleship!”
Stevenson retorted, stuffing the abrasive
bear back into her briefcase.
“Ah, but wait!”
Mr. Jeffries replied jovially, finishing placing
his miniature boats.
“Now, then, give me a co-ordinate.”
“Um, B6?”
Clarron said.
“Direct hit!”
Jeffries clapped his hands excitedly.
It was then that everyone noticed a tiny streak
of smoke shooting up from one of the ships
on Clarron’s board.
Glowing, it soared directly upwards, leaving
a trail behind it, climbing through the air
over the table.
Then, once it was above Mr. Jeffries’ board,
the little glowing projectile began to plummet
straight back down.
At once, the board members all realized it
was a miniature missile, some of them urgently
ducking under their desks before it struck
its target.
A small explosion erupted on Mr. Jeffries’
board, punctuated by a miniature fireball
and cloud of black smoke that wafted up only
to be sucked into the boardroom’s air purifier.
From the battleship that had just been hit
with the shrunken ordinance, the Wondertainment
execs could hear some tiny, barely audible
voices.
They were screaming and shouting in a state
of panic; ‘mayday, mayday’ and ‘abandon
ship, swim for your lives’ were the only
words anyone could clearly decipher.
“Battleship: Extreme Edition!”
Mr. Jeffries announced proudly with a chuckle,
met with looks of concerned from the board
members brave enough to sit back in their
chairs.
“While we’re on the topic of games,”
Mx Clarron spoke up again.
“I did have this.”
They produced a handheld video game player,
the kind that only featured one classic title.
Fortunately, the particular title was Pac-Man,
the distinctive music and flapping sound of
the titular character’s mouth instantly
recognizable even to the youngest members
of the Wondertainment Enterprises board.
“Come on, Kay,” one of the executives
sighed.
“We’re all waiting to hear the catch.”
“It’s, um, this one is actually pretty
horrible,” they admitted, handing the game
across the table to Mr. Glenridge.
Seemingly happy to be free from the Tamagotchi’s
pleas for food, he began absent-mindedly playing
Pac-Man.
“I mean, it handles well,” he observed,
guiding the yellow, mouth-flapping icon around
the maze, avoiding multi-colored ghosts as
he chomped on any dots in his path.
“It’s quite a throwback too, eighties
nostalgia is still hot right now, isn’t
it?
Oh, power capsule!”
Mr. Glenridge hit the corresponding buttons
to lead Pac-Man towards the larger dot, which
granted him a power-up ability to eat the
ghosts that were patrolling the maze.
Tapping away with both thumbs, he got Pac-Man
to follow in the path of one of the ghosts…
then the handheld game started screaming.
“Billy!
Billy, please, no!”
shrieked a tinny, 8-bit voice.
“Ma?”
Mr. Glenridge’s face went pale, drained
of all color as he stared horrified at the
game in his hands.
Pac-Man kept following the path of the fleeing
ghost, gaining on it.
The closer he got, the louder the compressed
screaming got.
“Billy, stop!
Don’t let it eat me, please, son!”
But sure enough, Pac-Man caught up with the
ghost and kept up his perpetual chomping.
As the ghost was eaten in the game, the built-in
speaker played the blood-curdling cries of
Mr. Glenridge’s mother over the classic
theme music.
Silently, with a look of pure shock on his
face, Glenridge put the game down on the desk.
“So, yeah, there’s that,” Clarron said
awkwardly.
“A Pac-Man game with the souls of dead relatives
trapped inside.”
“These toys are all… well, perfectly useless,
let’s be honest!”
the good doctor erupted.
“Are you all forgetting we have the SCP
Foundation breathing down our necks?
Surely any one of these abominations would
have them poking around and investigating
us even more.”
“How about this:” one of the execs interrupted.
“Picture Monopoly, but Site 19 edition.
We could really get our own back on the Foundation,
expose where their anomalies are kept, just
generally cause some trouble for them.”
“Oh, the playing pieces could be some of
the things they have in containment!”
another joined in.
“Instead of the shoe, the car, and the iron,
we might have… an anomalous shoe, car, and
iron.”
“And being sent to jail in the game would
turn a player into a member of their D Class
personnel!”
the first board member replied.
“Enough!”
the doctor’s booming voice silenced the
whole room.
“That is… without a doubt, one of the
most absurdly stupid ideas I have ever heard
in the history of this company.”
“With respect,” somebody spoke up.
“I think you’re all overthinking this.”
One of the board members who had been sat
at the furthest end of the table, keeping
quiet throughout the rest of the farcical
presentations, suddenly stood up.
Adjusting his tie, he addressed his fellow
Wondertainment executives.
“Doctor, you’d like our – apologies,
your – company to uphold its core purpose,
to make toys and reach people all over the
globe,” he stated.
“And, as a healthy added bonus, you’d
like to stick it to those killjoys over at
the SCP Foundation too.
So, why don’t we do something that will
cover all those bases?”
“That’s what we’ve all been trying to
do!”
Glenridge protested.
“But, like I said, you’re overthinking
it,” the exec replied.
“Let me show you all something.”
Casually, he produced a stylized plush.
The group leaned in, astonished to see it
resembled SCP-049, better known as the Plague
Doctor.
“We make plushies…” the board member
paused for dramatic effect.
“Of the Foundation’s SCPs.”
“Very intriguing,” Doctor Wondertainment
declared, finally turning their chair around
to face forward, examining the Plague Doctor
plush in their gloved hand.
Anyone who types that into their search engine
of choice will find high-quality plushies
of some of the SCP Foundation’s most beloved
anomalies.
There was a torturous pause; the members of
the board room could barely breathe, as Doctor
Wondertainment rose to his feet…
And began to clap.
“You son of a bitch.
I’m in.”
Now go and check out “SCP-001 A SIMPLE TOYMAKER”
and “ALL THE LITTLE MRS EXPLAINED”! for
more of the wondrous world of Doctor Wondertainment!